alors l'énergie éolienne si elle a le
vent en poupe at elle vraiment de
l'avenir est elle vraiment l'énergie du
futur une pollution visuelle ou bien
encore un drame économique annoncée
c'est l'objet de notre face à face avec
nous pour en débattre fabien bouglé
experts de l'éolien à hauteur de
éoliennes la face noire de la transition
écologique aux éditions du rocher
bonsoir fabien a bouclé son côté
frédéric lanoë directeur d'entreprise
ancien président de france énergie
éolienne bonsoir j'ai ici monsieur
lannoy et merci d'être avec nous alors
la tribune un de stéphane bern semble
rencontrer un certain écho auprès des
politiques qui vont tous deux leurs
commentaires aujourd'hui les éoliennes
ça devient un sujet éminemment politique
fabuleux doublé
bah écoutez vie si salutaire la tribune
de stéphane bern est salutaire vous
contrer les nombreuses fêtes news de
barbara pompili de ces derniers jours
tenue vendredi
tout d'abord les éoliennes ne servent
pas la décarbonation puisque la france
est à 80 % décarbonés et que les
éoliennes ne peuvent pas décarbonés
supplémentaires par rapport aux
nécessités déjà quitté carbonées et en
outre les éoliennes comme elle le
produit simplement 24 7 % de leur
capacité maximale de production oblige
l'organisation élèves peuvent
contrebalancer avec que j'appelle ça un
accueil promoteurs éoliens
c'est à dire des usines au charbon au
gaz et au pétrole c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle en allemagne
l'allemagne produit dix fois plus de gaz
à effet de serre la france mais oui
monsieur lanoë votre pays d'exemplarité
et bien avec 30% de charbon et 30% des
éoliennes produits puis fois plus de gaz
à effet de serre la france c'est un
échec retentissant
les éoliennes ne sont pas une et
l'énergie
ir et vont progressivement être
démantelées dans le cadre d'une
politique de démantèlement progressif en
tout cas que nous appelons de nos voeux
frédéric lanoë beaucoup de choses à
envoyer secouer la tête aux arguments de
fabien bouglé alors on répondait des
feuilles quiniou sur les éoliennes en
france et notamment par la voix de la
ministre de l'écologie écoutez monsieur
bouclé il est fiscaliste et juristes
pour le patrimoine
monsieur stéphane bern s'occupe de
patrimoine et se permet de parler de
sujets éminemment scientifique puisqu'on
en est là en face du les gens on sort
d'une crise profonde
on a vu qu'on a pu avec résilience
fournir l'électricité parce que les
éoliennes ont continué de produire wac
il faut changer notre mode de notre
logiciel est bien parce que qu'est-ce
qui arrive le plus grand des tsunamis
c'est celui du réchauffement climatique
et par rapport à ça qu'est ce qu'on nous
propose les vieilles solutions le
pétrole le nucléaire
or pourtant la semaine dernière puisque
vous si vous parlez de l'actualité la
semaine dernière l'agencé internationale
de l'énergie qui fait foi dans le
domaine qui a son siège à paris a sorti
un document en dix ans il faut
impérativement cesser tout
investissement dans les fossiles
immédiatement 80% des stocks connu
doivent rester sous terre et ont deux il
faut investir massivement et à 2050 dans
30 ans il y aura deux piliers dans le
mix énergétique mondial à 35%
ça sera le solaire et à 35% ça sera
l'éolien et ça c'est des spécialistes
qui le disent et pourquoi il le dit
parce qu'en fait cette énergie non
seulement aller les propres mais en plus
elle est devenue compétitive donc le
débat que maintenant c'est 280 faut pas
raconter des âneries c'est pas si
grâce aux subventions que vous touchez
non vous vous trompez m'a le plus sûr
des appels d'offres et entretenue autour
de 50 à 60 euros le mégawattheure mais
en même temps messieurs parce qu on vous
entend pas et autour de leur marathon
i did congolais mais là on voit les
procédés l'écossé des élections
scientifiques et techniques la cité
scientifique est ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que mes chansons et quelques
chemins
on a vu un sondage qui montre que 82 %
des français et c'est l'institut de
radioprotection du chrtr s'il le fait
les personnages que vous avez de chine
c'est vrai que ça fait partie d'un des
axes de ce débat c'est assez étonnant ce
qui se passe avec les éoliennes parce
que monsieur bouclé pardon la noé à
raison les français sont plutôt apprécié
les éoliennes 82% ont une bonne image de
l'énergie éolienne souffre souvent quand
ils sont à côté des éoliennes en direct
comment vous l'expliquez vous alors non
pas d'un sondage qu'elle était je ne
tends pas qu'on lit des finances et
france énergie éolienne dans le plan
pluriannuel de l'énergie à une
consultation menée par paul vi qui
montre que 70% des personnes se sont
opposés aux éoliennes
lorsqu'il ya des défunts d'hommes
réalisés dans les communes à proximité
des centrales éoliennes
il ya une opposition de 80% dans la
peste dans la presse quotidienne
régionale lorsqu'il ya des sondages
réalisés par les journaux qui a une
opposition de 80% des soldats
mais si l'entrée c'est comme si vous me
demandiez ce qui est raisonnable et
c'est répondre parce que ça va dans le
sens à excuser moi ça va dans le sens de
faire venir bové je voudrais vous faire
écouter le député l ère du vaucluse
julien aubert qui applaudissait à cette
tribune de de stéphane bern écoutez
bravo à stéphane bern l'éolien c'est
plus de 90 milliards d'euros pour une
électricité non stockables des acteurs
locaux ignoré des riverains excédés un
résultat carbone incertain aucune
écologie ne se construira durablement
sans l'homme et frédéric lanoë c'est
vrai que son bac il est très théorique
il existe c'est vrai mais quand on est à
côté les riverains soient ses excès d
comment vous vous l'expliquer mais je
lui explique parce que c'est du bon sens
on voit bien que c'est l'énergie
nationale j'entends beaucoup de
politiques et notamment de la droite qui
s'expriment contre l'éolien et je trouve
ça complètement incompréhensible des
gens qui se veulent conservateurs
devraient avoir conscience que la preuve
le premier des capitales c'est
l'environnement il nous faut le
conserver en 2d vend des gens qui ont
été prompts industrie devrait bien voir
qu'est une révolution industrielle qui
est en train de se jouer
on peut pas la laisser aux chinois aux
américains avec joe boyd et donne
maintenant et aux allemands et autres on
doit s'en saisir de même que l'industrie
française s'est saisie de l'automobile
donc là une fois à droite on ne
contractent pas toujours que
conservation l'environnement
promotion de ligue occupions 5000 à rime
avec les énergéticiens petite porte et
l'éolien longtemps outre seille vous
donnant katende qui a quand même trouvé
le temps s'il vous plaît l art après
l'autre merci
vous devrez qui depuis des années
ça arrange pour préserver les réserves
halieutiques
vous êtes en train de détruire aux
pêcheurs aux 2500 familles de vous et
vous monsieur vous êtes un détruire la
nature parler aux français qui voient
les éoliennes des figurines cela vous
êtes sur ce portail qui h mais sûrement
les dommages déjà que vous êtes en skype
vous parler en même temps l'un des très
longs s'il vous plaît comme ça on
sortira de ce débat en ayant appris
peut-être l'un après l'autre s'il vous
plaît voilà alors les gens parce que
c'est ce qui vient revient souvent
fabien bouglé sur les nuisances rapporté
fiable c'est ce qu'on a des données
vraiment fiables sur les nuisances que
provoquent les éoliennes sur les rivera
et après on laissera la réponse à
frédéric lanoë l'un après l'autre s'il
vous plaît ya quand même des normes les
unes ornithologique en particulier la
ligue de protection des oiseaux de cyber
internationale qui montrent eux il ya
une atteinte aux oiseaux qu'il que les
rôles gays sont des ou hachoirs à la
passe encore ua va passer très très rare
qu'elles étaient déchiquetés ces
derniers jours qu'on retrouve sur les
réseaux sociaux et la ligue de
protection des oiseaux a c'est un
communiqué est-ce en dix ans qui a des
amis lima 60000 rapaces morts ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que sea bird
internationale en espagne a fait un
rapport en 2011 qui précise qu'une de
plus millions d'oiseaux qui meurent pas
en espagne depuis lors ils ont été
financés par iberdrola qui le principal
promoteur espagnol
il a eu ce problème doit zone espagne et
on ne dit pas ça monsieur la lp au dic
c'est entre 1 et 20 oiseaux qui
éventuellement vont mourir par une
éolienne un chat errant ses 60 à 100 par
an et c'était lyon par les autoroutes et
les versements en revanche le fléau
numéro 1 a laissé moi je vous ai laissé
parler s'il vous plaît
lanoé monsieur google et s'il vous plaît
on est sur les nuisances effectivement
sur l'environnement la faune animale n'y
a pas que ça m'est déjà prenons dans
l'armée
des études sont faites et pour répondre
à la tribune de stéphane bern
les architectes des bâtiments de france
veille à ce qu'on se rapproche pas il ya
un périmètre d'exclusion du monstre
saint-michel et cetera
tout est fait avec beaucoup beaucoup de
précautions et des experts passent font
des relevés et non il est faux de dire
que c'était un choix d asseoir azot ddt
centaines d'études montrent que les
oiseaux passent au dessus ou en dessous
ou sur les côtés parce qu'ils voient et
elle tourne de plus en plus massivement
en revanche de quoi il meurt il meurt du
réchauffement climatique
marseille va devenir une fournaise
caniculaire ça c'est le jeu n'est en
effet vous n'avez toujours pas opposer
un début de solution de ce boulet depuis
le début ce débat ne l'est pas proposé
de suspendre le mans c'est bien ça cette
solution est là et le pays.le décarbonés
au monde monsieur la nouvelle star
arrive d'un volume utile
je tiens la formidable au cul mans c'est
quand même temps écouter s'il vous perd
on vous entend pas de demain il ya un
documentaire qui sort de charles simon
dieu qui s'est fait un documentaire de
documentaires et vérité qui s'appelle du
rêve à la réalité qui en 1h05 en détruit
toutes les fêtes news de monsieur lannoy
et de ses collègues lobbyistes de
l'éolien
frédéric lanoë on a compris frédéric
lanoë moi j'ai une question
j'ai une question d'un de nos vies quand
je vous écoute vous écharpés sur le
sujet avec beaucoup de passion et c'est
bien comme ça mais qui croire quand on
connaît mal ce sujet et comment être sûr
qu'il n'y a pas justement des lobbyistes
voilà tout simplement chacun défend ses
intérêts peut-être parfois financiers
et quelles sont les vraies raisons
objectives de ne pas vouloir ou de
vouloir de ces éoliennes elles ce qu'on
le saura un jour avec des données
fiables est clair vous avez quand même
la source du ministère de frédéric
l'adoré pour la réponse excusez moi
chacun là la traîne stratégie ces
oppositions systématiques
vous avez quand même le ministère de
l'économie et du développement durable
qui a mis un vrai faux qui est très
clair vous avez dans un agence
internationale de l'énergie caciques a
longtemps été pro pétrole puis pro
nucléaire et qui maintenant reconnaît
que la plus compétitive et la plus
propre ceo lien plus solaire il y aura
toujours une part pour le nucléaire
monsieur bouclé mais quand les réacteurs
vont devoir s'arrêter parce qu'on va pas
aller jusqu'à ce qu'ils pètent sont les
d'accord mais on peut pas les remplacer
par des opère pas ce que le pm c'est
trois fois plus cher que l'éolien et le
solaire
ce n'est pas une solution pour
l'économie française or maintenant on a
des usines
on a des usines à saint nazaire on a une
usine de pales à cherbourg on a en a ou
havre il faut les faire tourner un vrai
défi industriel et je pense que au
moment où on a un pays qui a une dette
abyssale
au moment où on a une économie du
chômage il faut aussi raisonner en terme
économique dont sort seulement 0 et donc
vous allez succès soit c'est à dire
juste avant que je pose est comment être
sûr voilà qui vous viennent en france
à ceci s'ajoute le monde de la pêche les
gens qui sont là pour protéger leur
métier les milliers de familles
françaises qui défendent leurs doutes
gras et leur métier qui va être détruit
pas ces personnes lobbystes éolien
voudrais rappeler que nous nous
défendrons le de manière totalement
désintéressée le bien commun nous
défendons la france ses paysages son
patrimoine
le capital holdings qui est installée au
sein même du ministère de l'écologie qui
s'appelle l'ofas te l'office franco
allemande à 30
énergétique car son siège social à
berlin et qui a ses logos et bien sûr
énergétique dans son ensemble des liens
que vous pour fonder lise installé c'est
bien la transition énergétique dans son
ensemble qu'on doit faire pour lutter
justement contre ces fossoyeurs de la
france de ses paysages et de son
patrimoine culturel naturel voilà
mais vous il pas qu d'autres les pylônes
électriques historiens pas tous contre
la tour eiffel surya pas du contrôle
mais le débat était et est passionné
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
d'avoir plus que jouer le jeu du face à
face aux ce soir fabien bouglé y avait
pas besoin de vous tous c'est trop
frédéric lanoë merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france